millions of people live every day with
severe pain it really doesn't matter if
you start hurting today or if you're
dealing with an injury from 30 years ago
dr devin at spinal care of nevada and
his gentle
method of chiropractic can help
when my back gets out of alignment it
pinches nerves
and nerve pain is pretty awful you
are just mentally exhausted from
this pain that just seems to go
like this all day long
and at times i cry sometimes it's a
lifetime of wear and tear we have old
accidents falls injuries we think
nothing about
what they catch up to us down the road i
came in and i was literally hobbling in
the door
you know i was bent over i couldn't even
stand up straight my wife
faye uh oh it's been probably now eight
months ago
she started developing uh tiredness
fatigue
she had headaches she had nausea started
getting some adjustments
and probably after about three four
weeks she started feeling a little bit
better
noticeably so and in about two months
magically so to speak she was fine
tunuka chiropractic
is a more gentle style of chiropractic
the the gentle approach avoids the the
twisting the cracking or the
manipulation
um and our patients just prefer that we
can treat a wide range of patients
uh young children um people who've been
in bad car accidents bad falls
maybe we've even had surgery before up
to
80 90 year old men and women with severe
osteoporosis and arthritis so really one
of the keys to our success
is our two-day workup day one we're
going to sit down
and i'm going to listen to our patients
and i mean truly listen we'll run a
series of tests
checking every range of motion of their
spine orthopedic neurological test
posture
and then we're going to take digital
opposing view x-rays these are some of
the best
type of films in our field i'm going to
study those i'm going to study the notes
so day two we're going to sit down and
i'm going to go over the findings and
listen if i can't help someone i'm going
to let them know and i'm going to get
them to the right doc if i can help
i'm very straightforward how long is it
going to take what's it going to cost
what's my insurance do or not do
because if you're anything like me you
don't want financial surprises and we're
going to get to work
and start getting some relief as soon as
possible my life's changed immensely
i'm pain-free where i used to have
shoulder neck pain wasn't able to lift
my arms
brush my own hair it's almost like a
relief
when he adjusts i can feel it
like that it's it's it's amazing
normally that two day workup
is 180 what we're going to do for
viewers of the show
is give it to the first 20 callers i
have to limit it
after that it goes up to regular price
for only 37
all right so dr devin said it right
there the first 20 callers
will pay 37 bucks for both
normally that's 180 dollars so you can
call that phone number
702566 hope
it's really uh hate when 566
have to look at the letters and figure
it out or you can just visit devon.com